- Do you know what the
best universities are
to get into a consulting
firm like McKinsey?
There are many opinions on that,
which are often based on gut feeling.
So let me try to bring
some objectivity into it
by looking into LinkedIn employment data.
So based on LinkedIn,
these are the top four universities
that current McKinsey employees attended.
Number one is INSEAD,
the French and Singapore business school
offering MBAs and Masters in Management.
Harvard Business School, trust
this needs no introduction.
Number three is Wharton School
from University of Pennsylvania.
And number four is London
School of Economics.
Does this surprise you?
Let me know in the comments.
Follow me for more consulting content
and career advice.